rejoignez-moi sur patréon pour accéder à
l'ensemble de mon contenu inédit des
épisodes spéciaux des cours en visio des
apérophilos un moyen simple de soutenir
mon travail tout en vous donnant matière
à penser je vous attends sur pas créole
le lien est dans la description
bonjour à tous
aujourd'hui on va parler d'Emmanuel Kant
Emmanuel Kant est un philosophe allemand
du 18e siècle c'est un penseur majeur du
mouvement des Lumières et même un
penseur majeur tout court
puisqu'il est celui qui va faire prendre
un tournant à la philosophie occidentale
et après lequel on ne pensera plus de la
même façon
on connaît surtout quand pour sa
philosophie morale d'ailleurs on en a
déjà parlé sur cette chaîne sa
philosophie morale fondée sur la notion
de devoirs et de respect de la loi
morale
mais en réalité c'est surtout sa
philosophie de la connaissance qui a
marqué l'histoire des idées
et aujourd'hui on va essayer de
comprendre pourquoi
alors tout le monde s'accorde à dire que
quand est un auteur extrêmement
difficile
il emploie un vocabulaire très technique
parfois d'ailleurs il reprend des
concepts de la philosophie en leur
donnant une autre définition
c'est un auteur tellement difficile que
Nietzsche le surnommait le grand chinois
comme quand on dit que quelqu'un parle
chinois pour souligner le fait qu'on ne
comprend pas ce qu'il dit
mais rassurez-vous on va reformuler ce
que nous dit quand on va simplifier son
propos pour tenter de le rendre un peu
plus accessible
alors de quoi compte nous parle-t-il
il nous parle de la connaissance et plus
précisément des limites de notre
connaissance
la question que quand se pose c'est que
met-il possible de connaître
et pourquoi est-ce qu'il se pose cette
question il se pose cette question parce
qu'il a l'impression que jusqu'à son
époque les philosophes ont passé leur
temps à parler de choses qu'on ne peut
pas connaître
ou à parler de choses sans se poser la
question de savoir si on pouvait les
connaître
quelles sont ces choses
il y en a trois
Dieu l'âme
[Musique]
et le monde
depuis Aristote et même depuis Platon
les philosophes parlent de ces choses là
c'était même ça l'essentiel du travail
des philosophes
parler des choses invisibles
parler des choses
supra-sensibles c'est à dire des choses
qui échappent à la perception
on appelle ça la métaphysique
l'étude de ce qui est au-delà du
physique
au-delà du matériel et de l'observation
parce que si les philosophes se
contentaient d'étudier le monde matériel
on les appellerait plus des philosophes
on les appellerait des physiciens
et bien ce que nous dit compte c'est
qu'en voulant parler de choses qui
échappent à la perception en voulant
parler de choses qui échappent à nos
sens
les philosophes en ont oublié de se
poser une question préalable
est-il seulement possible de connaître
ces choses là
c'est cette question qui va être l'objet
de son grand ouvrage La Critique de la
raison pure un ouvrage qui va avoir pour
objectif de définir les conditions de
possibilités de la connaissance
les conditions de possibilités de la
connaissance autrement dit les limites
structurelles de la connaissance
ce que quand appelle les limites a
priori de la connaissance
et quelles sont ses limites
et bien on va commencer par la première
limite qui est qu'on ne peut pas
connaître les choses qu'on ne peut pas
percevoir
pour qu'il y ait connaissance il faut
qu'il y ait d'abord perception
alors on va préciser les choses par la
suite parce qu'en réalité ce n'est pas
aussi simple que ça mais retenons déjà
que pour quand la perception est le
fondement de la connaissance
c'est même la toute première phrase de
son introduction je cite
que toute connaissance commence avec
l'expérience il n'y a absolument aucun
doute
donc cette phrase est très importante
parce qu'elle signifie que quand on
parle de choses qui sont hors du champ
de l'expérience hors du champ de la
perception
on ne se situe pas dans la connaissance
on se situe dans la pensée certes mais
pas dans la connaissance
et quand nous dit il y a une différence
entre penser une chose et la connaître
il y a des choses qu'on peut penser mais
qu'on ne peut pas connaître
par exemple vous pouvez penser que la
vie continue après la mort
vous pouvez le croire
mais fondamentalement vous ne pouvez pas
le savoir
vous ne pouvez pas le prouver
l'immortalité de l'âme c'est un objet de
pensée mais ce n'est pas un objet de
connaissance
et bien tout est là
tout tient dans la différence entre ce
que l'on peut penser et ce que l'on peut
connaître
et ce que nous dit quand c'est que les
philosophes jusqu'à lui ce qu'il appelle
les métaphysiciens
ont pris pour des objets de
connaissances ce qui ne soit en fait que
des objets de pensée
et c'est ça selon quand l'erreur
fondamentale de la métaphysique
la spéculation
les philosophes spéculent
ils font des raisonnements hors sol
raisonnements qui sont parfois très
complexes et très subtiles mais qui
reste dans le champ purement spéculatif
des raisonnements qui flottent dans
l'air
ils ne sont pas adossés à une réalité
observable
et ça ces problématiques
pendant des siècles on a trouvé ça
normal de parler de choses qui échappent
à nos sens
mais quand on dit non
stop
on arrête
on arrête avec ça
ça suffit de parler de choses qu'on ne
connaît pas
ça suffit de faire comme si on parlait
de choses qu'on connaissait
parce que c'est pas le cas
on spécule on conjecture on imagine mais
on ne connaît pas
c'est ça le geste de quand
remettre les pendules de la métaphysique
à l'heure
et mettre fin aux illusions de la raison
mettre fin à la croyance selon laquelle
la raison serait toute puissante et
qu'elle pourrait se dispenser de
l'expérience pour parvenir au vrai
d'ailleurs quand tu utilises une image
il dit qu'il faut faire comparaître la
raison devant un tribunal
le tribunal de la raison
afin de juger ce dont elle est capable
et ce dont elle n'est pas capable
la Critique de la raison pure c'est le
procès philosophique de la raison
humaine
alors il faut savoir qu'au départ quand
était plutôt cartésien
cartésien au sens où il adhéré aux
positions de Descartes sur les pouvoirs
de la raison
des cartes qu'on sait qu'il était
possible d'accéder à la connaissance par
le seul recours à la raison
par le seul recours à la pensée
c'est-à-dire sans recourir à
l'expérience
pour Descartes l'expérience c'est à dire
la perception c'était justement ce qui
nous induisait en erreur
donc au départ quand tu es d'accord avec
ça
et puis quant à lui Yum
yum qui explique qu'une pensée qui ne
s'appuie pas sur l'expérience on pensait
qu'il ne s'appuie pas sur la perception
c'est une pensée qui tourne à vide
et là tout à coup pour quand ça devient
limpide
bien sûr qu'on ne peut pas penser sans
expérience
bien sûr que la pensée a besoin de
s'appuyer sur un matériau qui est la
perception
quand tu écrira que yum la fait sortir
de son sommeil dogmatique
qu'il l'a fait sortir de sa conception
rationaliste de la connaissance
c'est à dire d'une conception de la
connaissance
fondée uniquement sur la raison et non
sur l'expérience
alors ça nous paraît une évidence
aujourd'hui
mais ça nous paraît une évidence parce
que du point de vue de l'histoire des
idées c'est Young qui a gagné
parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est l'empirisme
qui domine
et qu'on imagine pas une science qui ne
s'appuierait pas sur l'observation
mais jusqu'au 18e siècle c'était pas si
évident que ça
jusqu'au 18e siècle beaucoup de
philosophes considéraient comme des
cartes que l'expérience était trompeuse
que les sens s'étaient trompeur
c'est tout l'objet des Méditations
métaphysiques
montrez qu'il faut dépasser les
impressions sensibles
et bien quand va être le premier à dire
ok les empiristes ont raison
ils ont raison au sens où c'est bien
beau de vouloir utiliser sa raison
mais utilisez sa raison sur rien d'autre
qu'elle même ça suffit pas
il faut des supports de la connaissance
rationnelle
et c'est support de la connaissance
rationnelle ce sont les objets sensibles
les objets dont on peut avoir
l'intuition sensible
alors il faut savoir que chez Kant
l'intuition sensible c'est l'autre nom
de l'expérience sensible
le mot intuition n'a pas la même
signification chez Kant que chez les
autres philosophes et même que dans le
langage courant
les objets qu'il y a autour de vous vous
les percevez vous percevez leur forme
leur taille leur couleur
vous en avez l'intuition sensible
et bien ce que nous dit quand c'est que
les seules choses qu'on peut connaître
ce sont les choses dont on peut avoir
l'intuition sensible c'est à dire les
choses observables
donc ça c'est la première étape de la
réflexion de Kant sur la question de la
connaissance
la deuxième étape de son raisonnement ça
va être de se demander mais ce que je
perçois
ce dont je peux avoir l'intuition
sensible
est-ce que c'est bien la réalité
est-ce que c'est la réalité ou bien
est-ce que c'est la manière dont la
réalité m'apparaît
dans la réalité apparaît à mes sens
évidemment la réponse est dans la
question
dire est-ce que le monde tel que je le
perçois correspond bien au monde réel ou
seulement au monde tel que je le perçois
c'est une tautologie
mais c'est une tautologie fondamentale
et ça c'est quelque chose qui n'avait
pas encore été exploré par les
philosophes à l'époque de Kant
l'idée qu'il n'y a pas
identité qu'il n'y a pas équivalence
entre le monde réel et le monde tel que
je le perçois
et tel que je le perçois ça veut pas
dire seulement tel que moi je le perçois
ça veut dire
tel qu'on le perçoit
tel que l'être humain le perçoit
parce que c'est bête à dire mais notre
perception du monde rien ne dit qu'elle
corresponde à la réalité du monde
je vais prendre un exemple tout bête
les couleurs
les choses qu'on perçoit comme étant
bleu
est-ce qu'elles sont réellement bleues
est-ce qu'elles sont intrinsèquement
bleu ou bien ce que ce sont nos yeux qui
nous les font voir comme étant bleu
et c'est pas du tout idiot comme
question parce qu'on sait aujourd'hui
qu'il y a des tas de choses qu'on
perçoit d'une certaine manière non pas
parce qu'elles sont réellement ainsi
mais parce que notre perception est
réglée d'une certaine manière
on ne voit pas les infrarouges pourtant
ils existent
on ne voit pas les ultraviolets pourtant
certains animaux perçoivent les couleurs
différemment
pourquoi
parce que d'une espèce à l'autre les
organes de la perception ont des
différences
nous par exemple les êtres humains on
perçoit trois domaines de couleurs
le rouge le vert et le bleu
parce que nous avons trois types de
cônes
chaque type de cône correspondant à un
domaine de couleur
donc ce que nous voyons lorsque nous
avons l'intuition sensible d'un objet
c'est cet objet filtré par nos cônes
nos organes sensoriels filtre le monde
et donc lorsque nous parlons du monde
nous parlons en fait du monde en tant
que nous le percevons à travers un
filtre
nous ne parlons pas du monde mais de ce
qui nous apparaît du monde
nous ne parlons pas du monde mais du
filtre qui s'intercale entre nous et le
monde
c'est toute la différence entre ce que
quand appelle la réalité
phénoménale et la réalité en soi
la réalité phénoménale c'est la réalité
telle que nous la percevons
phénomène ça veut dire ce qui nous
apparaît
ce qui se manifeste
la réalité en soi c'est la réalité
indépendamment de notre perception
oui mais c'est bien gentil la réalité
mais la réalité est toujours dépendante
de notre perception
la réalité indépendamment de notre
perception c'est une réalité à laquelle
par définition nous n'avons pas accès
donc comment pourrait-on connaître
quelque chose à quoi nous n'avons pas
accès
il est là le problème
et c'est pas juste un jeu de la pensée
c'est pas juste jouer avec les mots et
dire la réalité n'est pas réelle et on
est des génies parce qu'on a compris
c'est pas ça
c'est simplement de dire on ne peut rien
dire du monde en dehors de ce que nous
percevons du monde
c'est une limite structurelle
une limite a priori
il y a une illustration de cette idée
que j'aime bien utiliser c'est l'exemple
de la pomme
une pomme verte
de quelle couleur est une pomme verte
vous allez me dire elle est verte
oui elle est verte
mais est-ce qu'elle est réellement verte
et ben non
rigoureusement parlant une pomme qui
nous apparaît verte elle n'est pas verte
elle reflète le verbe
elle renvoie du verre
parce qu'elle est constituée de
composants chimiques qui réagissent à la
lumière et que quand une pomme nous
apparaît verte
ça veut dire qu'elle absorbe le rouge et
le bleu et qu'elle renvoie le verre
on appelle ça la synthèse soustractive
des couleurs
et donc la couleur d'un objet
ce n'est pas la couleur de cet objet
c'est la couleur renvoyée par cet objet
ça change tout
on dit qu'un objet à telle couleur quand
il renvoie cette couleur
autrement dit la pomme verte c'est une
pomme qui est tout sauf verte
c'est quand même étrange quand on y
pense
et cette couleur sera captée par Marine
qui va envoyer un message à mon cerveau
qui va traiter l'information pour me
faire percevoir la couleur
donc la perception c'est le résultat
d'un traitement par le cerveau d'une
donnée rétinienne elle-même dépendante
d'une sensibilité rétinienne
quand je perçois une couleur je ne
perçois pas une couleur
je perçois l'effet d'un phénomène
rétinien
quand je perçois un objet ce que je
perçois en réalité c'est le
fonctionnement de mon œil
je ne perçois pas l'objet je perçois ma
perception
ce que nous dit quand c'est que toute
connaissance est fondamentalement limité
par les conditions de notre perception
toute connaissance et conditionnée par
les structures de la perception
d'où l'idée que la réalité en soi ce que
quand appelle le nous-mêmes nous est à
jamais inaccessible
nous sommes prisonniers de nos sens
comme nous sommes prisonniers des mots
avec lesquels nous pensons
on peut pas en sortir
on peut seulement avoir conscience que
ce qu'on perçoit ce n'est pas la réalité
mais seulement notre perception de la
réalité
quand ne parle pas des couleurs mais il
parle d'autre chose
il parle de l'espace et du temps
et il nous dit l'espace et le temps
constitue les formes a priori de la
sensibilité
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
ça veut dire qu'on ne peut rien
percevoir donc rien connaître en dehors
de l'espace ou du temps
l'espace c'est le domaine des objets
extérieurs
des objets physiques
ce smartphone ce stylo ce micro ils
occupent un espace
ils prennent place dans un espace
sans cet espace aucun objectif ne
pourrait exister
le temps c'est le domaine des objets
intérieurs
des étapes psychiques
un état psychique se caractérise par sa
durée
sans la dimension du temps pas de
ressentir intérieur
ce que nous dit quand c'est que nous
avons les perceptions de notre
équipement cognitif
c'est parce que notre sensibilité est
structurée par ces deux paramètres que
sont l'espace et le ton que nous
percevons les objets tantôt sous la
dimension spatiale tantôt sous la
dimension temporelle
et pourquoi c'est important
c'est important parce que ça veut dire
que ce n'est pas tant le monde qui est
de nature spatiale et temporelle
c'est notre perception du monde qui est
autrement dit l'espace et le temps ne
sont pas des propriétés du monde ils
sont des propriétés de notre perception
quand tu appelles ça l'esthétique prend
son mentale
esthétique parce qu'en grec esthéticos
ça veut dire sensation ou perception
comme dans le mot Anne esthésie
anesthésie c'est le fait de ne plus
avoir de sensations
et transcendantal c'est un mot qui veut
dire ce qui rend possible
alors attention il ne faut surtout pas
confondre transcendantal et transcendant
il arrive souvent que des gens emploient
le mot transcendantal pour dire
transcendant
et c'est pas du tout la même chose
on peut même dire que ces deux mots
s'opposent
transcendant c'est ce qui vient du
dessus
c'est ce qui est au-dessus du sujet et
qui descend vers le sujet
pour le transcender
transcendantal c'est au contraire ce qui
part du sujet
c'est le fondement
la structure interne
donc l'esthétique transcendantale c'est
l'analyse des structures de notre
perception
c'est pour ça que la philosophie de Kant
on l'appelle
idéalisme transcendantal
idéalisme parce que pour quand nous ne
connaissons pas le monde mais seulement
une représentation du monde
l'idéalisme c'est tout ce qui est lié à
la représentation
et transcendantale parce que cette
représentation a des conditions
elle a une structure
en l'occurrence l'espace et le temps
donc si on devait simplifier on pourrait
dire que l'idéalisme transcendantal
c'est la doctrine qui consiste à dire
premièrement que nous n'avons pas accès
à la réalité mais seulement à une
représentation de la réalité
et deuxièmement que cette représentation
de la réalité est structurée par deux
paramètres qui sont l'espace et le temps
alors on va souffler un peu
parce que j'ai conscience que c'est pas
facile
on va souffler un peu en expliquant en
quoi le projet philosophique de Kant est
quand même assez original
quand est un philosophe chrétien
c'est un protestant
donc il est croyant
comme Descartes et des croyants comme
d'ailleurs été croyant la plupart des
gens à cette époque
et pourtant quand tu diras on peut pas
prouver l'existence de Dieu
on peut pas la prouver
c'est pas banal
un philosophe croyant qui dit lui-même
qu'on ne peut pas prouver l'existence de
Dieu
autant se tirer une balle dans le pied
bah non parce qu'en fait quand tu es
juste honnête
et il est cohérent
parce qu'il est conscient contre le
domaine de la raison et le domaine de la
foi
il y a un fossé
Pascal l'avait d'ailleurs dit avant lui
Pascal disait vouloir démontrer
l'existence de Dieu c'est vouloir
démontrer l'indémontrable
ça n'a pas de sens
Dieu est ce qui est chape aux outils de
la rationalité
donc c'est peine perdu
quitte à croire en Dieu autant faire le
pari de l'existence de Dieu
parier sur l'existence de Dieu c'est
finalement plus honnête et plus cohérent
que de vouloir la démontrer
Descartes a voulu démontrer l'existence
de Dieu
il a voulu prouver que Dieu existe à
travers le sol instrument de la raison
et l'une de ses preuves ou plutôt l'un
de ses arguments
consiste à dire que si Dieu est bel et
bien un être parfait
il ne peut pas ne pas exister
sinon il ne serait pas parfait
puisqu'il lui manquerait quelque chose
c'est ça le raisonnement de Descartes
partir de la définition de Dieu pour en
déduire son existence
on appelle ça l'argument ontologique
l'argument par lequel on déduit
l'existence d'une chose à partir de sa
définition
et alors là quand ne va pas être
d'accord
qu'est-ce qu'il va faire contre
il va attraper des cartes par l'oreille
et il va lui dire
qu'est-ce que tu fais là
ta démonstration là
elle marche pas
c'est même pas qu'elle marche pas c'est
que c'est pas une démonstration du tout
tu n'as rien démontré du tout
tu as juste répéter deux fois la même
chose
qu'est-ce qu'il voulait dire par là
il voulait dire que quand on définit
quelque chose par exemple Dieu comme
étant parfait
le fait de dire qu'il existe parce qu'il
est parfait ça revient seulement à
répéter qu'il est parfait
si je dis tous les joueurs de tennis
gaucher sont gaucher
est-ce que j'ai démontré quoi que ce
soit
non
je n'ai rien démontré
j'ai répété ce qui était déjà contenu
dans mon premier énoncé
et bien ce que nous dit quand c'est que
des cartes fait la même chose avec Dieu
il déduit son existence d'une propriété
la perfection qui était déjà posée dans
sa définition de départ
mais ça c'est trop facile
on peut démontrer l'existence de tout ce
qu'on veut avec ça
si je dis quelque chose qui est obligé
d'exister existe
j'ai mis la conclusion dans ma prémisse
c'est de la triche
l'exemple de Descartes illustre le fait
que parfois la raison nous fait dire
n'importe quoi
ou plus exactement que la raison peut
nous conduire à des conclusions
contradictoires
à des conclusions antinomiques
ce que quand appelle les antinomies de
la raison pure
parce que de la même façon que Descartes
pensez avoir démontré l'existence de
Dieu par la raison
certains diront qu'ils ont démontré
l'inexistence de Dieu par la raison
en disant par exemple
tout ce qui existe à une cause donc si
Dieu existe il faut bien qu'il est une
cause mais si Dieu a une cause il n'est
plus Dieu donc Dieu n'existe pas
donc le problème de la raison c'est
qu'elle peut démontrer tout et son
contraire
elle peut démontrer que Dieu existe
comme elle peut démontrer que Dieu
n'existe pas
elle peut démontrer que nous sommes
libres comme un peu démontré que nous
sommes déterminés
et si la raison peut démontrer une chose
et son contraire c'est qu'il y a un
problème avec la raison
c'est qu'on peut pas entièrement se fier
à la raison
qu'elle a des limites
et là il faut bien voir ce que l'analyse
de cantine signifie
elle signifie la destitution de la
raison de son piédestal
la raison n'est plus le juge suprême du
vrai
donc ce que nous dit quand c'est que non
seulement notre perception a des limites
notre perception ne nous permet pas
d'accéder à la réalité en soi
mais en plus la raison elle-même a des
limites
or la connaissance étant le produit de
la perception et de la raison quand on
arrive à cette conclusion que la
connaissance est doublement limitée
limiter par les limites de notre
perception et par les limites de notre
raison
et de la même façon qu'il existe une
structure de la perception ce que quand
appelle les formes a priori de la
sensibilité
il existe une structure de la raison que
quand appelle les formes a priori de
l'entendement
donc on va voir ce que ça signifie mais
avant ça juste une petite remarque pour
bien souligner en quoi le projet de
compte constitue ce qu'on appelle un
projet critique
quand le premier philosophe qui a
cherché non pas à expliquer comment
connaître
mais expliquer ce qu'il était impossible
de connaître
c'est pour ça qu'on parle parfois du
criticisme conscient
la philosophie comme approche critique
de la connaissance
et si c'est aussi important c'est parce
que c'est ce qui a donné naissance à
l'épistémologie
c'est-à-dire à l'étude des conditions de
possibilité de la connaissance
une branche de la philosophie des
sciences
donc après quand on ne pense plus de la
même façon parce qu'on pense l'esprit
humain en termes de limite
en termes de défaillance
il ne s'agit plus de dire voici ce
qu'est le monde
il s'agit de dire voici ce qu'est le
sujet pensant
voici comment fonctionne le sujet
pensant
et voici pourquoi le sujet pensant
s'illusionne quand il pense être capable
de connaître le monde
donc je ferme la parenthèse pour en
revenir à ce que je disais juste avant à
savoir les formes a priori de
l'entendement
les formes a priori de l'entendement ou
les catégories de l'entendement ça veut
dire la même chose il y en a quatre
la quantité la qualité la relation et la
modalité
autrement dit pour quand tous les objets
que votre entendement est capable de
concevoir
il ne peut les concevoir que sous ces
catégories
vous ne trouverez pas une catégorie vous
ne trouverez pas un concept de la raison
qui échappe à ces catégories
il n'y a rien de pensable or de ces
catégories
ce serait comme vouloir imaginer une
nouvelle couleur
c'est pas possible
et bien là c'est la même chose mais pour
l'entendement
pour faire un parallèle même si
comparaison n'est pas raison
c'est comme quand Spinoza explique que
tout ce que l'homme est capable de
concevoir il peut le concevoir soit sous
l'attribut de l'étendue soit sous
l'attribut de la pensée
est-ce que ça veut dire que le monde
n'est constitué que détendu et de penser
non
ça veut dire que le monde n'est
connaissable que sous les attributs de
l'étendue et de la pensée
et bien la même façon la raison humaine
est structurée par des catégories de
pensée par un contenant de la pensée
et on peut rien penser hors de ce
contenant
raison pour laquelle on disait tout à
l'heure que la connaissance ne nous
renseignait pas tant sur le monde que
sur nos facultés de connaissances
elles-mêmes
connaître c'est d'abord connaître le
fonctionnement de l'esprit
et lorsque quand parle des connaissances
mathématiques qui sont censés être les
connaissances les plus fiables et les
plus objectives qui soient il nous dit
les connaissances mathématiques sont un
pur produit de l'esprit
c'est ce qu'il appelle des connaissances
a priori
c'est-à-dire que ce sont des
connaissances qui sont totalement
indépendantes de l'expérience
et bien les connaissances a priori les
connaissances logicomathématiques ce
sont des connaissances qui nous
renseignent uniquement sur la manière
dont l'entendement est structuré
on dit que les mathématiques sont
objectives mais ce n'est pas qu'elles
sont objectives
c'est qu'elles sont le pur reflet du
fonctionnement de notre raison
pour quand produire des connaissances
mathématiques ces produire une
connaissance de notre esprit
donc finalement ce que fait quand c'est
qu'il montre la relativité de notre
connaissance
relativité au sens où la connaissance
humaine est toujours partielle
elle est toujours conditionnée elle est
toujours
contrainte par sa structure
et dire ça à l'époque c'est faire un
grand pas sur le plan philosophique
parce que c'est cessé de voir la raison
comme un outil qui nous permettrait
d'atteindre un absolu
parce que c'est ça le penchant naturel
de la raison
vouloir atteindre l'absolu
vouloir atteindre la cause première la
fin dernière
le sens ultime
le penchant naturel de la raison c'est
la régression à l'infini
jusqu'à atteindre la vérité
mais ça nous dit quand ce sont des
illusions
il y a un plafond de verre au-dessus de
notre raison
parce que la structure du monde n'est
pas la structure de la raison
jusqu'au 18ème siècle il y avait une
sorte de sous-entendu une sorte de
croyance tacite selon laquelle la
structure de la raison correspondrait à
la structure du monde
mais non
elle est là l'illusion
quand le dit clairement
ce n'est pas la connaissance qui se
règle sur le monde
c'est le monde qui se règle sur la
connaissance
sur les possibilités de la connaissance
et la philosophie ancienne vise moins à
connaître le monde qu'à connaître la
connaissance elle-même
quand initie ce qu'on appellera la
révolution copernicienne en philosophie
ce n'est plus le monde qui est au centre
et le sujet qui cherche à le connaître
c'est le sujet qui devient central et
c'est le monde qui s'adapte à lui
le monde se conforme aux modalités de
perception et de compréhension du sujet
et parce qu'il s'y conforme
il se dénature
il n'est plus la réalité en soi
il devient la réalité phénoménale
la réalité perceptible et compréhensible
le monde qui gravite autour du sujet
c'est le monde en tant qu'il est perçu
et pensé par le sujet
ce n'est pas le monde comme absolu
quand des absolutises la connaissance
il la ramène à ses conditions de
production humaine
il introduit la subjectivité du sujet
pensant comme composant essentielles de
la connaissance de l'objet pensé
il renverse la hiérarchie sujet
la hiérarchie raison pensante et monde
pensait
c'est la raison qui devient l'objet de
la pensée
et non plus le monde
avec Kant la pensée se regarde pour la
première fois dans un miroir
je cite
il s'agit d'opérer ici un changement de
méthode analogue à celui qu'on accompli
les mathématiques dans l'Antiquité
grecque lorsqu’à la place des
tâtonnements auxquels elle s'était
livrée jusque là quelques grands esprits
sont genre à faire sortir la
connaissance de l'objet de la
construction a priori de son concept ou
à celui cas dans les temps modernes
accomplit la physique lorsque lieu de se
laisser conduire par la nature comme à
la lisière elle entreprit de diriger et
d'interpréter les expériences d'après
les principes même de la raison et de
forcer ainsi la nature de répondre comme
un juge souverain les auteurs de ces
révolution avaient compris que la raison
n'aperçoit que ce qu'elle produit
d'elle-même d'après ses propres plans
c'est cette vue que quand tentent
d'introduire dans la métaphysique afin
d'y opérer une révolution semblable à
celle qui ont produit de si heureux
effet dans les mathématiques et dans la
physique il compare encore l'idée
d'après laquelle il entreprend cette
révolution à celle de Copernic celui-ci
voyant qu'il ne pouvait venir à bout
d'expliquer les mouvements du ciel en
admettant que toute la multitude des
astres tournés autour du spectateur
chercha s'il ne serait pas mieux de
supposer que c'est le spectateur qui
tourne et que les astres restent
immobiles de même au lieu de supposer
comme on l'a fait jusqu'ici que toutes
nos connaissances se règle sur les
objets quand supposent que ce sont au
contraire les objets qui se règle sur
notre connaissance ils pensent pouvoir
résoudre ainsi ce problème qui est la
première question et comme une question
de vie ou de mort pour la métaphysique
comment une connaissance a priori des
choses est-elle possible la réponse se
résume dans cette pensée que quand
regarde comme la pierre de touche de la
nouvelle méthode c'est que nous ne
connaissons a priori des choses que ce
que nous y mettons nous-mêmes doigt
déduit cette conséquence contraire en
apparence au but que poursuit la
métaphysique nous ne pouvons avec cette
faculté dépasser les bornes de
l'expérience possible puisque la part
que nous apportons a priori dans notre
connaissance de la nature
certes précisément à la rendre possible
et qu'en dehors de cet usage elle ne
saurait avoir de signification notre
philosophie indique comme contre-épreuve
de la vérité de ce résultat une sorte
d'expérimentation qui a beaucoup
d'analogies avec celles que les
chimistes nomment souvent essaient de
réduction elle consiste à éprouver les
principes a priori de la raison en les
considérant successivement sous deux
points de vue différents d'un côté comme
nous faisons connaître les choses telles
qu'elles sont en soi de l'autre comme
nous les faisons connaître seulement tel
qu'elle nous apparaissent en vertu des
lois a priori de notre esprit ou d'un
seul mot à titre de phénomène s'il
arrive que dans le premier cas il donne
lieu à un véritable conflit de la raison
avec elle-même tandis que cette
contradiction disparaît dans le second
il sera démontré que notre raison
n'atteint que des phénomènes sans
pouvoir s’étendre aux choses en soi
lesquelles bien que réelles en elle-même
nous reste inconnu
depuis le XVIIIe siècle l'homme a pris
conscience de ses limites
il a pris conscience que le monde
n'était pas tel qu'il se le représentait
et qu'avant de vouloir connaître le
monde
il fallait d'abord commencer par se
connaître soi-même
quand fut l'initiateur de ce projet
ce projet
d'autocritique de la raison humaine
une raison qui est désormais son
caractère faillible
sa partialité
sa relativité
et qui appelle à ne pas tout
miser sur elle
à ne pas lui faire tout endosser
la principale illusion de la raison
étant qu'on appelle généralement raison
notre propre conception de la raison
et qu'on appelle irrationnel
ce qui ne rentre pas dans cette
conception
c'est la connaissance est quelque chose
qui nous tient à cœur
et que la raison est notre seul moyen
d'y parvenir
espérons que tous les êtres qui en sont
dotés
reconnaissent
qu'une autre raison est possible
je vous remercie
[Musique]